et
nous avons évidemment notre réseau
eurostar onishi strauss coopération
russe nous avons lance tu pouchkine
fondation au monde rue c est toute une
série de mécanismes qui avec le soutien
étatique à son chargé
de la promotion de la langue russe de la
culture russe ce programme étatique les
a assurés l'approchent systémique à ce
travail et je vais pas vous cacher que
eu l'idée de former ce programme est un
outil qui est de soutien de leurs seins
gruss cette idée est apparue non
seulement parce qu il faut plus de
coordination pour ne pas faire à part
prier les efforts et les moyens mais
aussi meilleur parce que la présence de
ce programme on montrera le financement
de ces mécanismes parce que si on
compare
nos efforts avec celui d'autres pays qui
font promouvoir leur langue
natale c'est l'institut goethe et on
sait que cervantès à la française au
conseil britannique évidemment les
volumes de financement
pour les collègues étrangers sont
beaucoup plus élevés et je crois qu'il
faut corriger ces déséquilibres et nous
comptons à votre soutien merci beaucoup
à la fraction la russie juste et
missionnier love et monsieur numérise
qui se prépare cher sergei
aujourd'hui à la menace à la profession
du lest rémy c'est ma silva ont réussi
est extrêmement élevé par le passé la
majorité des migrants surtout du
tadjikistan et de l'ouzbékistan a qui
viennent sans visa à part des millions
créer de grands problèmes pour les
citoyen pour la société pour la
communauté
en faisant part de différents schémas de
trafic en travaillant de différents
marchés illégaux surtout même plus un
parti de différents circuits criminels
dans les pays de golfe
la mer rouge avons connu il ya environ
juste 9 % de migrants il n'y a pas de
problème de schémas grille de schémas
noir peut-être ça vaut déjà le temps ça
vaut le coup de faire la large issement
de cette législation des visas des
services ti invitation personnelle avec
la responsabilité personnelle pour les
migrants qui viennent travailler ici
s'il vous plaît il faut suivre l'agenda
et le temps prévu
ouais je moi je dois mentionner tout de
suite eu la réponse à cette question la
réponse détaillée avec les faits
concrets vous le trouverez dans les
documents écrits qui ont été distribués
parmi les députés avant mon intervention
mais le un sens de notre approche
consiste à ce que on peut pas comparer
les uns migrants aux contres ou va aux
émirats arabes unis au qatar avec ce que
notre vont sur le territoire de la
fédération de russie
pour ce cas concret des pays du golfe
ces migrants n'ont jamais été un citoyen
dans seuls états unis quand un homme
c'est un événement historique tout à
fait récent qui peut être évolué
différemment mais qui a sans doute
influencé de façon négative à la vie des
gens ordinaires qui ont tu cette
habitude de se déplacent se déplacer sur
les territoires de saut un grand pas de
prix sans entrave
évidemment ces processus général dr
réaction différente dans la société nous
voyons les émotions du fonds
sont générés par des différents
incidents avec les la participation des
migrants venus des routes publiques et
avoisinantes et évidemment nous
accordons les tensions particulières à
ce sujet depuis assez longtemps
c'est le ministère des affaires
étrangères qui en est chargé ah parce
que c'est le ministère même qui est
responsable pour les fonctions de
service et migratoires
et le département appropriée est
présenté au sein de la commission pour
les affaires des compatriotes à
l'étranger que je préside merci
concernant les migrants c'est les
questions adressées aux ministères des
de l'intérieur et je n'attends que je
sache chez nos collègues feront tout le
nécessaire pour mettre de l'ordre dans
le dossier et y compris par le voix de
signer des accords avec les pays qui
nous présente le flux important des amis
grands sceptiques east and big east and
visant à assurer la création des centres
de formation des migrants sur les
territoires des républiques
susmentionnés ces centres doivent être
utilisés pour
s'assurer de la connaissance
nécessaire de la langue russe et la
connaissance des lois et les traditions
de la fédération de russie hall votre
soi que atteindre l'idéal comment on peu
partout dans l'activité humaine c'est
ça c'est compliqué mais on peut
témoigner que l'opération de ses centres
en flottant sera de façon positive ah ah
ah là au développement de ses relations
merci infraction nous voulons maintenant
messieurs karine que se prépare cheikh
guèye à merci beaucoup pour votre de
rapports bien détaillé qu'on nous voyons
tous ces dernières années à la soft
pavois russell n'est pas si fort que
comme nous ne pourrions compter
malheureusement un haut diplomate seront
refoulés parfois les médias comme un art
à château-d'oex y
subissent des pressions et un poste dans
les réseaux sociaux sont éliminés en
même temps nos partenaires étrange et
élargissent leur présence est en
déséquilibrant le monde autour comment
est-ce que les mystères des affaires
étrangères voit son activité pour
remettre en place cet équilibre qui sont
les outils efficaces pour qu'ils soient
utilisés dans cet axe merci beaucoup
moi je n'obtiendrai d'utiliser le terme
cette fameuse fausse porte parole russe
parce que par vent c'était la force
plutôt soviétique a parfois sauf parfois
dur vous savez au cp dur est alors soit
par l'ocp la lave puissance
douce et c'était plutôt le ballet la
culture l'art et c'est de ça qu'il
s'agit maintenant
s'agit en fait à ce que notre très
attractifs comme l'est pas comme le
peuple comme la nation comme la
civilisation
et la capacité d'atteindre ceux qui en
sont intéressés mais tant dans le cadre
de cette stratégie de dissuasion de la
russie dans ce domaine ainsi que la
dissuasion de la chine l'occident
s'efforce non seulement à nous
faire contourner pas en ses alliés
agressif en l'air en pourcent de
l'armement en rapprochant ses centres
structure militaire plus proche plus
près à nos frontières
l'occident continuait les tentatives à
mines et les
positions de notre homme course douce
sauf que nous avons su former après la
fin de la guerre froide et nous savons
le faire d'une façon efficace je dois
dire mais il s'efforce à
miner la confiance à nos médias qui
apporte de la vérité au moins une autre
partie de vérité
il l'interdisent
il se force non seulement
à influencer les pays sur tous les
continents au pour qu'il refuse à en
voir des affaires avait nous quand le
secrétaire d'état des états unis à
l'époque de monsieur trempe fait en
tournée en afrique et appelle le pays
qui l'accueille en visite officielle de
refuser toutes sortes de contacts
commerciales avec la russie à la chine 1
sous prétexte que ces deux pays pour
suivre leurs intérêts
le créatif et les états unis le faut
justement pour le bien-être de la
population locale et on le fait sans
moindre équivoque les entraves à notre
progression dans le monde la progression
de la promotion de notre culture de la
production de notre philosophie c'est
entre autres sont faites de façon assez
sérieuse est un exemple assez crayon
c'est le sport
oui de multiples fois là le dire la
russie a accepté que
d'affirmer que les sportifs ne doivent
pas être utilisés
comme des sujets d'expérimentation de
des pages mais cette hystérie qui est
actuellement en cours à tous les forums
sportif elle est évidente et est
inacceptable nous travaillons tous ces
vecteurs et sont obligées à le faire en
simultanément avec la quête de solutions
d'autres à mission dont nous avons déjà
parlé aujourd'hui il s'agit de 7,2 ce
renforcement de la tension politico
militaire et comme tout récemment
en pôle édition des états unis a déjà
dit la force et en vérité nous sommes
d'accord
merci
chers sergei
les députés de la demande et à recevoir
les demandes des citoyens russes qui
sont divisés avec l'aide aux enfants en
cours de différents obstacles tout
d'abord sont liées du fait qu'ils sont
citoyen de nations différentes
malheureusement la russie avec certains
pays n'a pas défini le mode législatif
pour protéger les intérêts de leurs
enfants parce que chaque pays a sa
propre vision et sur les circonstances
légitime il ya beaucoup de maires qui
sont divisés avec les enfants comment on
pourrait changer de la situation pour
avoir le résultat aux intérêts des
enfants qui se trouvent en otage des
divergences entre leurs enfants
une partie de la question que monsieur
kalachnikov est déjà entamée aujourd'hui
sur or la cité n'était des enfants dans
les mariages mixtes pour le moment si un
enfant est né sur le territoire de la
fédération de russie cet enfant lui ou
elle reçoit de façon automatique la
société russe si l'enfant est né à
l'étranger
l'enfant issu d'un mariage mixte c'est
la question qui ne peut être résolu un
qu'avec le consentement de deuxième
parent n'ayant pas laissé traîner tes
russe votre question est encore plus
large et c'est le ministère d'éducation
qui cherchait un plutôt de ce dossier et
je pense que la réaction plus
professionnelles pourraient être donnés
par leurs représentants de ce ministère
je mets un mot le ministère des affaires
étrangères nous participons à ce travail
avant tout d en assurer l'accompagnement
des citoyen qui
ce centre ouvert à une telle ou telle
situation dont on veut parler en dehors
du territoire national de la fédération
de russie
est à cet égard je tiens à souligner
encore une fois que la question a été
discutée à la commission gouvernementale
pour des affaires des compatriotes à
l'étranger et aussi bien au cul à la
commission criaient les initiatives
présidentielles
dollar us 2 du parti la russie unie pour
la coopération internationale le soutien
des compatriotes à l'étranger là
évidemment il le manque en
tout syrie des mesures qui doivent être
concertées nous avons de différents
points de vue mais je suis persuadé que
si nous allons nous faire guider par les
intérêts de nos citoyen et leurs enfants
no 11 ont la possibilité de nous mettre
d'accord entre une ou les ministères et
entre les ministères le parlement merci
députés indépendants
merci chers sergei vous avez remarqué
dans votre
l'occident collectif élabore les règles
qu'ils imposent aux autres pays en même
temps les ministères des affaires
étrangères russe ne considère pas ces
règles comme la dernière vers est
évidemment qui continue à mener sa
politique indépendant mais
malheureusement sur le plan économique
nous vivons toujours suivant
les règles budgétaires qui viennent
depuis les années 1990 à en investissant
les revenus du gaz et du pétrole dans
les activités haut des pistes ranger ça
concerne les mêmes règles du commerce
international du commerce que nous
suivons du façon unilatérale
probablement ça vaut déjà le coup et
c'est le temps de faire la révision de
tous ces règles sur le plan économique a
pourrait respecter les intérêts de
l'économie nationale sans respecter les
règles de l'extérieur
or pour des raisons claires c'est la
question pas plus tôt à peser a mis au
ministère des affaires étrangères c'est
les questions au pour le gouvernement
nous avons des engagements
internationaux nous avons
l'analyse réalisée en continu de la
manière de respecter ses engagements
internationaux par noé par nos
partenaires au sein de différents
structures internationaux l'organisation
mondiale de commerce la banque mondiale
et autres et la banque centrale et les
ministères concernés
sont chargés d'évaluer à quel point cet
équilibre est respecté et à quel point
les engagements sont respectés à long
terme pour n'est pas sans savoir que
nous aspirons et mettant je parle de la
part de mon ministère mais ce sont les
ministères qui doit être prise par le
gouvernement nous aspirons à réduire
notre dépendance du dollar américain et
les américains nous aident de façon
active à le faire parce qu'ils le font
parce que tout le nécessaire tout le
possible pour miner la confiance envers
à cette devise et à la rendre risqué
pour des pro commerce international non
seulement pour la russie mais pour
d'autres pays demandez comment t il
exige des rites et la coopération dans
le domaine militaire aux techniques de
nos partenaires comme l'inde l'egypte ce
ne sont pas de petits pays la turquie et
nos stimulons le passage des devises
nationales à dans le commerce bilatéral
et ça fait générer des discussions à
l'armée à part mais les politologues
politologue et les économistes
occidentaux
tertio nous réduisons nos réserves
internationales guerbet en dollars
américains et ce processus reste pas
sans réaction et non seulement le
spécialiste à l'occident et aux états
unis commencent à se poser des questions
où elles vont
avoir des problèmes réels et nos
opérateurs économiques est récente
7la fasse passer les passions des
relations économiques le banque centrale
a inventé en systems un des messages
rapatrier ceux qui a utilisé un parmi
mes approches aux témoins de
l'efficacité de ce système évidemment il
faut peaufiner encore quelque chose et
c'est pas aussi stable est que swift
pour le moment mais ça fonctionne et
alors je pense que c'est cette fois que
nous devons à poursuivre est ce qu'il
faut le faire plus rapidement moi je
suis pas le mieux placé pour le dire
c'est pas spécialiste mais je crois à
titre personnel et qu'il est important
de ne pas déséquilibrer l'économie
qui cet équilibre est critiqué par tout
le monde mais quand même cet équilibre
persiste et ça nous permet d'avancer
merci fracture kprf parti communiste
cher vous avez déjà dit l'a déjà
mentionné des problèmes de soutien de
lang rustan lépi de la civi parce qu'on
voit la réduction du nombre des écoles
russes et le nombre parce qu'il ya
beaucoup d'écueils vous n'êtes pas de
manuels et de livres en russe mais ce
problème on ne peut pas être résolu par
la construction des écoles il faut à
vouloir
de bons professeurs qui sont capables de
faire la formation et les études un
russe nous avons déjà commencé à
travailler sur le projet de loi avec le
soutien du ministère de l'éducation nous
allons envoyer les professeurs en russe
avec le bon salaire correct avec
l'arrivée messieurs prima kova en tant
que dirigeant de rose sa chronique
histoire
la situation s'est améliorée mais il
faut avoir le soutien de le vraiment
dans la fédération de russie est cher
s'habiller comme on est ce que vous
considérez le soutien de ce projet de
loi qui prévoit l'envoi des professeurs
en russe pour faire la promotion d'un
gosse dans la suite merci à propos
durant ma réponse à la question
précédente sur la langue russe moi j'ai
entamé les mesures systémiques et qui
sont prises dans le contexte on a parlé
de la situation en tunisie et dans
certains autres pays où l'activité
législatif d'une façon ou d'une autre
concerne le statut de la langue russe
cette question pour nos sens au
prioritaire à l'iran les relations avec
tous nos alliés et en cuir ici en
kazakhstan où la langue russe a un
statut officiel et nous ne partons de la
position que nos alliés
font un respecter le statut fixé au
niveau législatif de la langue russe
qu'on vous le savez l'année suivante or
sans de la coi a été a proclamé à
l'année de la langue russe comme la
langue de communication internationale
on commence déjà à la préparation à la
tenue de cette année et ça nous donnera
une opportunité importante de voir
comment
quelle est la situation avec à notre
langue le camp des puissantes
dans notre pays nos alliés et on a parlé
déjà aujourd'hui de ce projet de l'école
russe qui est en train d'être créés en
tadjikistan on a un projet similaire en
arménie lorsqu'on construit en bâtiment
tout près équipe et on est les
les instituteurs les formateurs sont à
former
on a deux versions soir on y envoie des
processeurs
pour une période de quelques mois ou
jusqu'à une année
soit on reçoit les professeurs de notre
pays partenaires pour passer le stage en
russie
sa fonction un principe mais je suis
persuadé que n'a jamais trop de
professeurs trop dans ce secteur c'est
pourquoi je trouve votre initiative très
utile
[Musique]
cher sergey ces derniers temps on voit
l'intensification du processus
d'intégration entre la russie de la
biélorussie dans le cadre de l' états
unis maintenant on va
élire le parlement de l'état il eut fini
comment est ce que vous voyez et qu'est
ce que vous en pensez si on place dans
la ville de smolensk à le centre
parlementaire entre les deux ni deux
états oui le rendre en tant que centre
et capitale de l'état unis parce que
c'est vraiment il se trouve au milieu
entre minsk et moscou et en cas
d'adoption de cette loi pas ce que ça va
donner l'impulsion à la région de
smolensk merci
dans notre corps de
ballet ans
nous avons de multiples missions qui
sont fixés non seulement la création des
parlements unis
on y trouve aussi les missions de
création d'une devise unique et danse
entre des missions uniques mais ce sont
des missions aux perspectives à long
terme pour le moment les priorités à
importantes comme les chefs d'état l'ont
déjà affirmé c'est la réalisation de 28
provinces programme qui en leur totalité
sont emparés dit qu'elle est très
important pour la promotion de
l'intégration
et je sais que mes collègues du
gouvernement avec leurs homologues bien
le russe
un travail de prêt à mettre m
un jour ces programmes une faut deux
trois années avant les résultats de ce
travail
est ce qui nous permettra de
évoluer les pas à apprendre avec le
fondement déjà nouveau évidemment ce
sont les présidents qui prendront les
décisions
mais le vecteur de notre progression
doit être que doit être rapide mais a
bien fondé rééquilibrait pour prendre en
considération tous les facteurs
qui sont de nature à participer dans les
résolutions de sept programmes
d'intégration important et quant aux
small est ce que c'est un résoudre
ensemble
d'actions
russie juste
mais madame collin qui se prépare
cher sergei plusieurs partenaires
étrangers
utilisent la soi-disant nov part d'une
façon agressive dans les pieds de la
suit à part les gens par des
journalistes à pour des blogueurs pour
faire la division entre ces états et la
russie notre ministère des affaires
étrangères mènent un grand travail parce
que nous avons nos organisations
n'augmente and mail leurs activités sont
divisés l'espace on nous affaiblissons
nos positions à l'étranger dans ces
conditions et tous faut avoir des
mesures actives avec
l'implication des organisations non
gouvernementales
probablement il faut élargir les
possibilités de recentrer ni stock au
mollet il faut savoir
que sa section langue mandingue qui va
faire la promotion de la culture du code
russa pour intensifier les médias pour
et grandir l'écho talent pour la
formation des étudiants étrangers en
russie quelles sont les options de
coopération entre les ministères qui
sont capables qui sont possibles merci
j'ai déjà mentionné aujourd'hui que
cette sof pas aux forces douce
à l'absence en termes plus haut
connu le monde pour le moment c'est les
domaines et lons lüthi parmi les plus
importants de la qu'il était
international faisait de tout à fait
vous avez tout à fait raison et
l'occident depuis plusieurs années
après cap qui aujourd'hui à prix
d'envergure
c'est le cap vivante à l'implantation de
toutes sortes d objets dans la politique
internationale visant à forcer
les pays étrangers à apprendre les
modèles développement
proposé par l'occident et dans la
majorité écrasante des cas l'option est
intéressé à donner lecture développement
à diviser nos voisins de la fédération
de russie
et à long terme d'interdire les états de
prendre le cap amicale envers la
fédération de russie la majorité
écrasante de ces ong camps sont créés
avec des fonds à budgétaire par exemple
des états unis de l' agence de
développement
étranger des etats-unis foreign office
britannique et d'autres structures qui
sont financés par le budget par les
états et font re distribuer ces fonds a
pour des ong ou alors majorité écrasante
on trouve la direction des anciens
fonctionnaires
de l'appareil de l'état de nos collègues
occidentaux là nous avons moins
d'expérience à l'époque de l'union
soviétique et nous avons eu cette
fondation russe de la paix et d'autres
organisations non gouvernementales y
compris les organisations des jeunes est
pour le moment sur le compare avec ce
qui se passe c'est une goutte dans mr
mais nous avons créé un fondation o2
soutien de la diplomatie publique
fondation green cove qui d'après son sa
charte son statut doit financer les
organisations non gouvernementales et
russe aspirant à apprendre le niveau
international l'argent manque et je
rappelle encore une fois les budgets des
structures étrangères analogique a
aussi trop distrait ou à l'institut
pouchkine les budgets des organismes
similaires à l'étranger sont beaucoup
plus élevés que les nôtres le problème
est connu depuis longtemps
nous y travaillons avec le soutien
fondamental du président et ces
dernières années nous avons su renforcer
un peu le financement et nous allons
poursuivre ce travail précis nouveau
jean merci voulait même dame boudina qui
se prépare chercheur guèye
est ce que les mystères des affaires
étrangères suppose le développement sur
le plan de développement de leurs
relations de ce qu'on a 10 ans de ce
qu'on appelle la diplomatie des
communautés parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
contradictions qui ont du mal être
traité au niveau intercommunal sp peut
être traitée en utilisant d'autres voies
de communication de sur le plan de la
protection des droits des gens de la
médecine de presse des ressources
naturelles à notre avis ça peut
affaiblir la tension
que la diplomatie officielle elle subit
et ça pourrait améliorer l'image de
notre pays est encore deuxième question
est ce que vous infligez la possibilité
de créer une agence spécialisée et qui
pourrait fonctionner deux sur cet axe
merci
pas très bien compris ce que ça signifie
la diplomatie des communautés alors
avant de répondre à cette question si je
suis prête à soutenir la création d'une
agence à ce sujet il faut que je
comprenne ce que c'est que la diplomatie
et de communautés si c'est ce que nous
appelons maintenant la diplomatie
sportive ou un scientifique qui est mais
évidemment pas la diplomatie des canons
la diplomatie de bea scientifique qui
des jeunes
qui sont en train d'être formés d'une
façon active et sans souffle et de
l'autre les autorités s'il s'agit de ça
évidemment il faut le soutenir
et je dois dire qu on soutient en
particulier il n'en faut pas parce que
ce sont des activistes que le fond mais
pour répondre pour donner la réponse à
votre question c'est pour la première
fois que j'ai entendu ce terme la
diplomatie des communautés si vous
pouvez m'envoyer une note
explicative à ce sujet nous allons
donner les réactions nous prouverons
l'opportunité à le discuter plus tard
merci fraction russie unie madame
boutines à marina
ensuite monsieur que le médecin qui se
prépare
monsieur servier il ya beaucoup de nos
compatriotes qui sont privés de liberté
à l'étranger qui sont et maintenant on
aimerait avoir plus de visibilité en ce
qui concerne la misère en prison de nos
compatriotes restent vont nous voyons ça
concerne beaucoup de pays a des
centaines de russes en particulier il ya
des poursuites et en penalan en
graissant en chine à aux etats-unis dans
d'autres pays qui le subissent dites
nous si vous cliquez sur les mesures
prises et par les mystères de cette
étrangère pour protéger les intérêts et
les droits de nos compatriotes et non
citoyen qui sont interpellés à
l'étranger surtout surtout prétexte
artificiel
évident c'est un sujet assez importante
qui prend beaucoup de temps notre
travail dans nos relations avec les
forces de maintien de l'ordre de la
fédération de russie est avant tout le
paquet générale le comité d' enquête
alors nos aspirants faire de manière de
donner un accès immédiat à ces gens
souvent on a des propos mal fondé
parfois on a même en assiste même à des
provocations au cul par exemple les
états unis et entreprennent à l'égard de
nos compatriotes très connus gouttière
chaîne que c'est les neuf et toute une
série d'autres
c'est un virus
là le problème est un multi facettes y
compris la nécessité de faire respecter
les accords d'entre aide
dans les dossiers pénaux qui les états
unis
mineurs sans nos
envoyés les documents sur à les
accusations contre nos
concitoyens avant tout dans le domaine
de la criminalité cybernétique au lieu
de le faire ont ils exigent
d'arrêter cette personne dans l'état de
ce présence et les états surtout les
états de l'europe ne peuvent pas objecté
à leur grand frère
atlantique
parfois nos compatriotes violent les
lois dans
leur pays de séjour parfois on a des
situations
c'est extraordinaire comme par exemple
la sri lanka nos scientifiques y ont
rattrapé des insectes et en fin de
compte c'est ils ont attrapé quelques
insectes
qui font l objet de vénération
religieuse et on a mis presque une année
et demie pour les libérer mais en fin de
compte on a su le faire et ces
scientifiques ont été condamnés à qu'ils
ont sur six et ils ont payé une amende
et notre hors communauté des affaires à
payer cette amende qui était assez
importante et alors c'est juste pour
dire que les lois du pays dessus jour il
faut les il faut les prendre en
considération nos au fond des pages
appropriées sur notre site internet du
ministère et avant de visiter un pays il
faut
prendre connaissance de sa législation
ça concerne tout le citoyen si vous avez
eu quelque sorte de relation qui
pourrait intéresser les états unis ne
pouvons pas prévoir tout un tas de
choses mais à en prenant en compte ses
habitudes inacceptable est agressif qui
sont maintenant utilisés par washington
l faut les prendre en considération
aussi bien que l'exigence de respecter
les engagements internationaux et le
travail pour chaque cas particulier
comme nous le faisons pour boot hirschel
et en chine qu'aux et d'autres
compatriotes emprisonnés par les états
unis
c'est de rester prudent au maximum dans
cette situation assez fragile surtout
lorsque quelqu'un a des connaissances
particulières ou des contacts
particuliers sur le territoire des états
étrangers lorsque se prépare à faire une
visite à l'étranger il faut être
attentif merci parti communiste
cher sergei
l'analyse des révolutions colorées de
couleur sur tanguay la russie en
moldavie au kazakhstan
dit que l'outil d'organisation de ces
oppositions de masse d'une part ce sont
des ong qui sont gérés par des
ambassades des états de ce qu'on appelle
de nos partenaires et nos alliés et
ensuite il ya vraiment un grand nombre
d'étudiants qui font leurs études grâce
à un budget par exemple de la polonia en
biélorussie où il ya plus de 100000
d'études en roumanie plus de 20 minutes
de moldavie ou ont fait leurs études à
vous connaissez très bien que pendant
les
20 ans du passé
les effectifs des excès un public de
l'asie centrale et font leurs études en
turquie est ce que pensait que ce serait
juste de resterez les quotas pour les
mêlées terre et pour les cellules sur le
plan de les écoles supérieures pour
intensifier et agrandir le nombre des
étudiants
c'est très important ce travail réalisé
par des établissements d'éducation
civile et militaire
est dans le cadre des mystères défense
et du ministère de l'intérieur je suis
d'accord avec vous les chiffres absolus
ne sont pas comparables avec les
exemples que vous venez de mentionner et
là encore une fois le ministère des
affaires étrangères réalise le la
politique qui est
plus généreuse parce que maintenant on
peut dire que nos épées maison pour à
des frais quotidiens mais en général
c'est notre économie notre stabilité
notre sécurité qui en souffrent nous
soutenons ce que je veux dire
merci fraction
cheikh sarr gay je ne peux pas ne pas
faire part de nos préoccupations en ce
qui concerne le futur de l'union
eurasienne il ya deux trois semaines à
cause de l'attaqué terroriste à les
bâtiments al matin ont subi la
destruction heureusement nous avons non
seulement la seule part mais aussi la
force du rpt un saut forme
des troupes sous l'égide ou le décès et
d'après à le traiter de l'intrusion
économique surtout almada en 2001 4 on
prévoit la mise en place du régulateur
supranationale sur le plan économique
mais tout se passe très bien sûr le bac
nomique sous l'égide du conseil eux
prennent sur le plan com et
dans les pays de l'est c'est on voit
l'ajournement sans arrêt l'adoption de
décisions prises en plus la crise des
prix de 15 e du gaz nous permet de
comprendre
qui sont les intérêts et qui sont les
hôtels et les menacer qui apparaissent à
cause du non respect des droits des gens
c'est pour ça qu'il faut surtout faire
attention à ces zones theron qui se base
sur la corruption
au l'union économique eurasiatique
étant donné que c'est déjà vraiment
union d'intégration 1 et dont nombreux
de ton grand nombre de pays de coopérer
avec mais il faut dire que c'est une
union à ces jeunes si vous regardez à
quel état de développement on a trouvé
le l'union européenne
quelques années seulement après sa
création ce serait assez illustratif
mais en même temps je suis tout à fait
d'accord tu nous devons être plus actifs
aux plus créatifs même
et
est en plus grands pays de l'union
économique eurasiatique la russie doit
ressentir sa responsabilité pour son
développement c'est le cas
inévitablement on y trouve des aspects
liés avec les subventions une fondation
eurasiatique une banque eurasiatique ont
été criés leur activité et
[Musique]
développer de façon continue et je crois
qu'il s'agit
des outils parmi les plus importants qui
doivent être promues dans le cadre de
l'union économique eurasiatique les
questions qui doivent y être envisagée
ces questions doivent être concertées
avec eux
l'activité de l'organisation industrie
t1 de sécurité collective et par exemple
dans le domaine de la sécurité
écologique qui concerne peut-être
particulièrement les les recherches
scientifiques
mais en même temps or
dans sur le territoire de la plupart de
nos voisins on trouve de laboratoire
biologique de pentagone et il est assez
compliqué de comprendre ce qu'ils font
là dedans pour le monde sont en train de
finaliser le processus de négociations
avec nos voisins qui ont abrité des
laboratoires susmentionnés pour assurer
la transparence de leur travail de leur
fonctionnement pour que n'y trouve plus
des militaires étrangers parce que ça
ça quitte le domaine de santé
représentant en danger à la sécurité
écologique
ce qui doit nous faire rapprocher
les agendas
de la communauté des états indépendants
de l'organisation du traité de sécurité
collective et d'autres
infractions ici juste pour la vérité
cheikh guèye évidemment nous soutenons
complètement l'activité du ministère des
affaires étrangères surtout sur le plan
de soutien de nos compatriotes c'est
vraiment une norme travail que vous avez
dit on est loin de l'idéal mais quand
même il faut toujours le continuèrent à
part on est préoccupé par les droits de
nos compatriotes et qui sont déjà
citoyen de la fédération de russie mais
qui vivent à en dehors de notre
fédération de parce que nous avons
environ 2 millions de
nos citoyens qui vivent en permanence à
l'étranger pour cette raison ne sont
préoccupés par la situation et dans les
pires keanu voisine et probablement
qu'ils sont les garanties au niveau sur
le plan législatif au niveau
gouvernemental il pour protéger les
intérêts les droits de nos citoyens qui
vivent à l'étranger problème il faut
avoir une relation législatives merci
beaucoup de votre réponse
si en compatriote
séjourne de façon permanente dans
d'autres pays en gardant satiété russe
comme dans notre législation c'est la
même chose c'est quelque chose se passe
avec lui des bons ou des pas très bon
dans notre pays
étant en teneur de deux passeports il
est soumise à la législation sur les
territoires
la législation de l'état sur le
territoire duquel il ce jour nous
faisons de même chose
nous avons des cas particuliers par
exemple
état comme en russie biélorussie
là nous avons un accord à spécialiser
pour égaliser les droits des acteurs
économiques et des citoyens aussi
on a beaucoup fait
c on y trouve l'une des deux
opportunités de comment on peut
progresser dans le domaine de la
protection des droits dans d'autres cas
à l'absence de tels documents
d'envergure arabisante à l'alignement
des droits des citoyens il faut conclure
des accords
spéciaux
jeu
être plus concret si vous avez des
exemples des situations qui
font du tort à nos gens dans les états
voisinant je me serais reconnaissant de
nous les signaler pour que nous
puissions région
cherche argué juste l'avait du jour
dolan j'ai été à tiraspol et où j'ai
parlé avec nos compatriotes où il y en a
environ 200 milles
russes qui vivent là-bas et la question
principale qui préoccupe les gens
surtout les problèmes pouvant dessus que
vous avez déjà mentionné c'est le
changement des passeports nationaux et
la délivrance de nos passeports surtout
à l'époque de pandémie en 2020 2021
arrêter le fonctionnement des consulats
parce qu'il ya déjà une queue qui prend
à peu près six mois pour que vous ayez
le nouveau passeport est ce qu'il est
possible d'intensifier
les invectives à pourrait réduire les
que juste devant les consulats de la
fédération de russie à l'étranger
probablement il faut avoir d'autres
mesures de soutien de nos compatriotes à
l'étranger parce que c'est pas un secret
qu'il ya plusieurs étapes qui nous
voisine et réalise des mesures de
motivation et de stimulation pour que
nos citoyens reçoivent des passeports
d'autres états
on venait d'exposer les causes de cette
situation il ya un mois et demi jusqu'à
l'été précédent c'était en état
d'urgence et les services du consulat
ont été suspendus pour des causes et
petits mots logique et à partir de l'été
de 2021
on ressort ses services
du compte cela évidemment on a une queue
de plusieurs milliers de personnes
surtout pour des questions des
passeports dès que la situation
épidémiologique et la termine nous lui
avons envoyé nos spéciaux tiraspol et
lezons
obtenaient leur
proposition concernant l'équipement et
le personnel nécessaires qui doivent
être
précipité sur les lieux pour assister le
travail du consulat sur le terrain et je
pense que nous allons résoudre ce
problème d'ici quelques temps traction
russie unie merci
chercheur gay le parti russie unie un
projet historique fédéral qui s'appelle
mémoire historique et où nous tâchons
une grande attention au respect des
tombes militaires surtout nous tâchons
grande importance à cette question à
l'étranger le ministère et affaires
étrangères continue son activité pour
commémorer à cette mémoire
à votre avis est-ce que la base
législative et efficace et suffisante
qui sont les activités et les efforts
menés par le votre ministère et comment
la douma d'état de l'assemblée fédérale
pourrait vous aider là dessus et la
dernière sous gestion au blé mais on
pourrait proposer ces questions on sauve
hauteur pour la commission russe sur
l'activité est là comme coopération
internationale on peut le faire mais moi
je dirais pas que la situation actuelle
exige des mesures extraordinaires non
ensemble avec le ministère de la défense
qui a des structures appropriées pour le
travail de collaboration avec des
représentants dans les pays où ces lieux
long terme en et des monuments sont
nombreux avant tout il s'agit des pays
de l'europe de l'est
moi j'y vois pas la nécessité des
mesures extraordinaires le gouvernement
ne débloque le financement nécessaire de
façon régulier lorsqu'on y trouve roque
quelques entraves souvent c'est lié avec
des cas particuliers qui ne sont pas
nombreux
les questions législatives de régulation
des lieux d'alternants sont soulevés
parfois maintenant on est en train de
discuter les questions liées à
l'enterrement de l'ecap d'orgueil avec
nos collègues japonais là on a une
particularité on a une initiative de le
faire ré enterré sur notre territoire or
au sud
de la région de sakhaline mais là c'est
un exemple ou là
l'ambassade a été actif à assurer
la sécurité la commémoration de cet
enterrement
pour le reste les détails sont nombreux
et cette question fait partie de cette
liste des questions écrites que nous
avons reçues et pour lesquels nous avons
donné des réponses dans le document qui
vous ont été distribués avant notre
réunion d'aujourd'hui je vous assure que
cette question fait partie de l'éventail
des questions qui sont au contrôle
permanent mais quand un mois là on n'a
pas besoin des mesures extraordinaires
le travail je suis son plan prévu
merci beaucoup je cherche à rien il n'y
a plus de question ils tous sont accusés
mais c'est clair que l'intérêt est
énorme et on s'est mis d'accord que
chaque fraction
va faire un rapport et va poser leurs
questions vous aurez la possibilité dans
votre parole de clôture de vous adresser
aux représentants des factions des
partis surtout qu'ils vont prendre la
parole dans le cadre de cette heure
gouvernementale maintenant on passe la
parole à monsieur hugues à 9
maintenant on propose à messieurs
jirinovski de se préparer
cher colère dans le monde un avion plus
de 200 pays et seulement juste deux pays
et nous et à l'angleterre les deux
pendant les 2 500 agents n'ont pas perdu
leur souveraineté à ce que
à l'époque où il y avait des
ennemis juste à côté de moscou les états
unis n'existait pas
[Musique]